Hello, I'm Berna Lidero with VOA 60 America for April 2nd.
President Obama says 7.1 million Americans have signed up for health insurance plans...
...under the Affordable Care Act,...
...passing the goal the administration made of seven million registered by the Monday deadline.
The enrollment website had been riddled with technical problems.
More than 4.8 million visits were made to HealthCare.gov...
...and two million calls were made to the call center Monday.
Secretary of Defense Chuck Hagel is in Hawaii to host a meeting of defense ministers...
...from the ten countries that make up the Association of Southeastern Asian Nations or ASEAN.
Following the conference, Hagel will launch his fourth official trip to the Asia Pacific Region.